Hello everyone,
welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul and welcome to another
edition of mystery languages.
If this is your first time watching a
mystery languages video,
they'd let me tell you how it goes.
I'll play you a sample of a language or
a couple of samples of a language and
you can listen and guess what each
language might be.
You might not get the exact language,
but you might get the region or the
language family or something like that,
and that's a partial success in itself.
Today's language samples were submitted
by Lang focus viewers via instagram,
so I'm especially excited about today's
episode,
so let's get started.
Please listen.
Yes,
some of upper management Snow Heidi,
who never came in Kakapo cookie bites
one year ago.
Has that thought about tune on united.
I live Aristo covered cocky,
mucin,
and lookup.
What's a good had not hired?
Now let's look at a few samples with
writing.
Yes.
The gunnel mechanic authority boost.
Not good care there today.
Yes.
Chimp,
Joshy,
ICA echo.
So what language do you think it might
be?
The language is Armenian.
Armenian is the official language of the
Republic of Armenia,
but more than half of it speakers live
in other countries in Armenian minority
communities.
It's a member of the Indo European
language family,
but it forms its own branch of Indo
European because it's linked to other
languages in the family are not really
known,
but it has borrowed a large amount of
vocabulary from Persian,
so Persian speakers might recognize a
lot of words in Armenian.
The stress and Armenian generally falls
on the final syllable of the word.
Not always,
but it usually does,
unless the word has the definite article
or a possessive adjective at the end.
If we read along with the sentences we
heard before,
we can notice that the stress usually
comes at the end.
Yes,
mechanic authority.
How boost
on this recording this word sounds like
it has the stress on the first syllable
like Connie,
but in other sources it sounds more like
Connie with the stress on the second
syllable.
That might depend on the sentence level.
Stress of the sentence as a whole.
Not Good.
Kevin,
today.
Yes.
Chimp,
Joshy,
ICA.
There are two standard varieties of
Armenian western Armenian,
eastern Armenian,
which have some significant differences.
The variety that you heard in the
samples was eastern Armenian.
This map shows the distribution of
western Armenian and eastern Armenian
dialects at the beginning of the 20th
century,
but most speakers of western Armenian
now live in diaspora communities.
Okay.
Now onto the next language.
Please listen night.
Mr.
Mr Wyangela on where I'm going to say.
Let's see.
One.
I ended up repeatedly take old,
worn out.
I don't plan on.
We don't know.
We're flying night.
Galileo Galilei Pitney's only leak Amman
at Tennessee Pitney.
Pitney Barlett beating the bottle.
All of us are not.
Are polycystic comfy together.
Amman,
where I in say,
I mean not in good.
Tal.
Why then?
People are really,
really wicked.
Not.
Tell going,
tell about why Sarafina Pitney Garden
Wall.
Now let's look at a few more sentences
with writing.
Meanwhile,
I'm buying some clothes.
She borrowed the book from the library.
Me.
Now I'm going on tonight,
so what language could it be?
Cool.
The language is Jamaican Patois,
as the name suggests.
Jamaican Patois is spoken in Jamaica.
It has around $3 million native
speakers.
It's an English based creole that
developed in the 17th and 18th centuries
through contact between African slaves
and English speaking slave owners.
The official language of Jamaica is
English and Jamaican.
Patois is spoken on a continuum with
standard Jamaican English.
That means that in some situations
speakers will be essentially using
standard English with a characteristic
Jamaican accent.
Well,
in other situations,
speakers will mix English with varying
degrees of Patois and at the very casual
end of the spectrum,
speakers might use Jamaican patois
exclusively.
The three sentences that we saw on the
screen,
we're pretty close to standard English,
but the longer reading that you heard
was full on Jamaican Patois,
but we do see some grammatical and
phonological changes in those three
sentences.
Take the third one.
For instance,
now I'm going on tonight.
Jamaican patois uses me as the subject
pronouns rather than the negative is now
instead of not and noticed that there is
a double negative with no being used
where any would be used in English.
Notice that going to is abbreviated to
go on and of course the pronunciation is
different to Dina and tonight are close
to the standard English equivalents just
with slightly different pronunciation
and spelling to match and onto the next
language.
Please listen.
Yeah,
we at the illegal hit on my eggs.
Salmon on your Buddha,
Allah Aleda a late hit our,
let's say a Nicholean household in order
to Arizona.
So
next we'll look at a few sentences with
writing.
I do.
Hi.
I'm able to take away.
That's in the morning.
We had AP.
So what language could this possibly be?
The language is what our need is an
indigenous language of South America.
It's spoken by over 6 million people,
including most of the population of
Paraguay,
where it's an official language
alongside Spanish.
It's also spoken in parts of neighboring
Argentina,
Bolivia,
and Brazil.
It's a member of the Tupi language
family,
which consists of around 70 languages
scattered throughout South America.
One feature of gluttony that we can
notice is that every syllable consists
of a consonant plus a vowel or a vowel.
A syllable cannot end in a consonant and
there are no consonant clusters.
To me,
this gives the language a pleasant
light,
floating quality kind of sing song me,
but without tones.
Another thing that adds to this quality
is squat.
On these nasal sounds,
guarani has six oral vowels and six
nasal vowels.
Also,
all voiced stops are either pre,
nasally,
before an oral vowel or initialized
before a nasal valve.
There's also nasal harmony,
meaning that stressed nasal vowels cause
other surrounding sounds to become nasal
as well.
We can see an example of this in this
sentence.
I do a session on her.
This is the word for clothes and this is
a future efforts showing that the known
will be obtained in the future.
This ethics has a nasal vowel which
makes the earlier vowels,
nasal as well.
Listen for it.
I do,
I do.
All right,
so let's check out one final language.
Please listen.
Schumer and Macau,
I guess on show,
Maurice,
fair alum,
non show mercy.
Maurice Rutherglen,
mosquito ligand faking tele fish.
I guess Domico of Mcclellan.
Komatsu is marching on spouse,
pre atomic dome fain.
Now let's look at a few samples with
writing,
but welcome Ada cannock for she lower
Air Issaquah,
own Liberland,
neve egg,
Dinair gigamon knocked,
so what language do you think it might
be?
The language is Irish,
as you can probably guess.
Irish is the historical language of
Ireland.
It still spoken as a native language
there by a minority of people and has
learned as a heritage language by most
others to varying degrees.
It's also known as Irish Gaelic and is a
member of the Celtic language family.
One interesting feature of Irish is that
all consonants have two forms abroad
form and a slender form depending on the
surrounding vowels.
There are three broad vowels in three
slender vowels that determine which form
of the consonant is used.
The slender form of the consonants are
palatalized,
which generally sounds like a place to
write after the continent.
If we look at this word,
piano,
we see this consonant twice.
The first is before a narrow vowel,
and the second is after abroad vowel.
The broad form is God,
but the narrow form is like,
ha ha.
There are similar Paris for all
continents.
We can see another example of this in
the word junior.
The d sound is next to a narrow vowel,
so what's palatalized like deer or Jay
Vignette yet?
I don't know if all speakers say the
narrow consonants the same way and to be
honest,
I can't hear it in this word on the
recording.
We listened to it,
but I can hear it in this sample from
the [inaudible] website.
10 Deanna,
the genius in this sample.
We can hear the narrow d sound as well
as a narrow end,
which makes the sound.
Yeah.
Well,
that's all for today's mystery languages
video.
Thanks to all the Lang focus viewers who
submitted their language samples via
instagram.
There will be more of mystery languages
videos in the future,
so follow me on instagram to stay in the
loop.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram,
especially instagram.
That's my favorite and that's where you
can keep in touch with me more than the
others.
And once again,
thank you to all my patrion supporters,
especially these amazing people right
here on the screen.
They are the top tier patrion
supporters.
So many thanks to them as always and to
everyone else.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.